we've talked
most of today except for a little bit
computer science mostly today about a
productive life
um how does love friendship and family
fit into that
is there um do you find that there is a
tension
is it possible for relationships to
energize the whole process to benefit
or is it ultimately a trade-off but
because life is short
and uh ultimately we seek happiness not
productivity
that we have to accept that tension yeah
i mean i think relationships is the
that's the found that's the whole deal
like i thought about this the other day
i don't think context was i was thinking
about if i was going to give like an
advice speech
like a commencement address or like
giving advice to
young people and uh like the big
question
i have for young people is if they
haven't already bad things are going to
happen
that you don't control so what's the
plan right like let's start
let's start figuring that out now
because it's not all
some people get off better than others
but eventually
stuff happens right you get sick
something falls apart the the economy
craters the
someone you know you know dies like all
sorts of bad stuff is gonna happen right
so how are we gonna do this like how do
we like live life and life is hard and
in ways that is unfair and unpredictable
then relationships is the that's the
buffer for all of that
because we're wired for it right i went
down this this rabbit hole with digital
minimalism i went down this huge rabbit
hole
about the human brain and sociality
it's all rewired it's like all of our
brain is for this like everything
all of our mechanisms everything is made
to service
social connections because that's what
kept you alive you know i mean you had
your tribal connections is how you
didn't
starve during the famine people share
food etc um
and so you can't neglect that and it's
like everything and and people feel it
right like there's no
our social networks are hooked up to the
pain center it's why it feels so
terrible when you miss someone or like
someone dies or something right that's
like how seriously
we take it there's a a pretty accepted
theory that the default mode network
like a lot of what the default mode
network is doing so the sort of the
default state our brain goes into when
we're not doing something in particular
is practicing sociality
practicing interactions think because
it's it's so you know crucial to what we
do
it's like at the core of human thriving
so i've
more recently the way i think about it
is like relationships first
like okay given that foundation of
putting like and i don't think we put
nearly enough time into it i worry that
social media
is reducing relationships strong
relationships strong relationships where
you're sacrificing non-trivial
time and attention resources whatever on
behalf of other people
that's the net that is going to allow
you to get through anything
then all right now what do we want to do
with uh
the surplus that remains may want to
build some build some fire build some
tools
so put relationships first i like the
worst case analysis from the computer
science perspective
put relationships first yeah because
everything else is just
uh assuming average case
assuming things kind of keep going as
they were going and you're neglecting
the fundamental human
drive like we we have we talked about
the board of instinct we want to build
things we want to have impact we want to
do productivity that's not nearly as
clear-cut of a drive of we need people
you